Just to recap and tie in some of the things we've covered earlier in
this lesson, I would say that this is very much an author driven narrative.
Partly because it's static, but more importantly, I as in author decided to
make the red circles slightly larger and to represent the home team.
So I dictated what information I wanted to draw attention to,
which other information may not be as striking.
And even by the simple fact of making the home team red,
and every other team matches blue, as an author,
I've influenced how a reader might interpret the graphic I've presented them.
And in closing, I just wanted to come back to where we
started before were even live coding.
We're trying to communicate our insight and our message.
In the case of this chart relating to the globalization of the world, and
also capitalization of the gains in an effective manner.
And again, just to remind you,
always be aware of biases in your data, yourself, and your audience.
And always consider how your audience might interpret or
interact with your visualization.
And I'll leave you with one last open-ended question.
Have we achieved what we set out to by communicating our message?
I encourage you to think about and post your thoughts in the forum about,
what works about this visualization, what could be improved, and
also whether the next step is an iteration on the scatter plot like this or
something more drastic where we change.
The complete form and
structure as we take one step closer to best communicating our message.